l'eau et le bien naturel le plus vital
mais c'est une ressource mal partagée 60
% des réserves mondiales de doses se
trouve dans neuf pays
borloo n'est pas une ressource
inépuisable deux milliards de personnes
dépendent pour leur approvisionnement de
nappes phréatiques jeunes moins
profondes
aujourd'hui menacée par une utilisation
excessive
le problème touche même des pays où les
réserves sont abondantes comme le canada
et les états unis
bien des facteurs entrent en jeu la
pollution la déforestation les
changements climatiques qui entraîne
l'évaporation de l'eau avant que celle
ci n'ait le temps de remplir les nappes
phréatiques
il y aussi le gaspillage les fuites
l'élévation du niveau de la mer qui
menace les sources d'eau douce dans des
grandes villes comme shanghai et dhaka
il y a aussi la hausse du niveau de vie
qui entraîne par exemple un changement
des habitudes alimentaires
on mange plus de viande dont la
production requiert de 6 à 20 fois plus
d'eau que la production de céréales
il ya aussi la croissance des besoins
énergétiques
l'extraction du pétrole des sables
bitumineux par exemple nécessite dix
fois plus d'eau que le pétrole classique
avec l'accroissement de la population
mondiale on prévoit que d'ici 2050 la
demande en eau va augmenter de 55 %
l'humanité devra apprendre à consommer
moins et mieux
[Musique]